[Musique]
bienvenue au château de versailles pour
cette émission spéciale vous montrer
tout ce qui est de nouveau les
rénovations des spectacles les
promenades pas tout ce qu'on peut faire
un état à versailles ça s'appelle
d'ailleurs à l'état à versailles
et vous voyez que parfois les thébains
il pleut aussi un denis verdier manioc
vous êtes le directeur développement
culturel de la mrc
c'est vrai qu'on a vécu une période un
peu compliquée avec la grille la crise
sanitaire ne cesse de versailles avec
une période un peu compliquée il y avait
à peu près combien 8 millions visiteurs
chaque année
oui mais million et demi de visiteurs un
corps 2019 qui a été l'année
exceptionnelle sur une dizaine de
millions pour tout le parc quand on
compte un million et demi de visiteurs
en fait ce sont les gens qui visitent le
château les jardins les trianon les
écuries et donc évidemment 2020 avec la
crise sanitaire
ça tombe bien sûr bien sûr ça a même été
un vrai choc est très violent
on est à peu près à 20% aujourd'hui de
ce que nous avions avant l'acte et
sinclair et et grasse et bien sûr public
français très bien très majoritairement
parce que nous même si versailles a
toujours été visitées façon importante
par le plus français mais nous n'avons
plus qu'aujourd'hui voilà il n'ya pas il
n'ya pas les touristes
là encore j'ai pas encore on commence à
les sentir arrivé alors par shaw si je
puis dire il
un élan de solidarité et qui s'est fait
jour il y avait des donateurs d
absolument versailles a pu profiter en
quelque sorte de cette triste période
pour accélérer selon mouvement de
travaux d'entretien de restauration
importante qu'il s'agisse de du cabinet
du roi par exemple qu'il s'agisse des
salles napoléonienne que nous voulons
dire mais est également d'autres espaces
qui sont en finition de restauration
comme les appartements intérieur de la
reine et puis également a trait à
trianon la maison de la reine avec ses
fabriques autour dont le boudoir qui
viennent d'être récemment réouvert
c'est ça c'est que vous avez un peu à
profiter parce que le mot de m mais pas
le bon mais enfin vous avez utilisé ce
moment ses serveurs pour des
restaurations absolument formule c'est
ça c'est comment décide d'ailleurs de
ces restaurations pas ce que c'est on va
on va le voir avec le cabinet duras et
des oeuvres absolument incroyable
commissaire restauration ce qui préside
un petit peu au choix c'est des
opportunités aussi lié aux mécènes que
nous pouvons savoir qu'ils ont des
logiques de de préférence de choix par
rapport à l'heure à leur orientation
propres qu'il s'agisse d'entreprises ou
de mécènes privés et donc c'est aussi
l'actualité de des acquisitions
d'oeuvres ou de mobiliers qui reviennent
dans les collections qui nous
amène à reconsidérer un espace et à le
restaurer pour mettre en valeur l'objet
revenu dans ses murs alors y est c'est
restauration va on va en parler puis on
va s'attarder un peu sur les aspects
notamment cabinet sublime elle est
privée du roi bien rire c'était c'est un
endroit formidable parce que c était au
fond par le roi de la croate serbe et
c'était là où le roi passé le plus de
temps
c'est exact c'est vraiment au coeur du
château et c'est un lieu de vie très
important à partir du règne de louis xiv
n'avait pas le même usage de l'aide de
la vie professionnelle puisqu'il n'avait
pas de bureau et quelqu'un se fait
véritablement installé ce bureau est
juste à côté un cabinet dépêche un
cabinet de travail pour le personnel qui
travaillait directement avec lui et puis
on parlera aussi du napoléon napoléon
versailles s'est dit l'histoire assez
assez intéressante faut bosser il peut
pas d'idées à versailles parce que c'est
le symbole de l'ancien régime le poids
du bar mais s'y intéresse quand même
absolument il a d'ailleurs tout à fait
imaginer un temps finalement s'y
installer mais il sent s'installer au
même endroit de la vie de cour dans ses
origines effectivement d'ailleurs on l'a
on a des tissus on a tout un ameublement
qui pourrait être installé qui avait été
commandée
malheureusement napoléon son règne a été
importé il n'a pas eu le temps de mettre
ce projet à exécution
mais il regardait vers ça absolument
passionnant il avait d'ailleurs vécu
pour ses travaux de réaménagement au
trianon comme vous le savez il ya un
petit appartement de l'empereur qui est
qui est très intéressant à découvrir
pour découvrir l'intimité de napoléon et
voir comment ils vivaient dans ces
espaces mais aussi marie louise bien sûr
petite fille et bien sûr à la nièce de
marie-antoinette donc quelque part
refusée par l'intéressé comme absolument
et puis alors je vais aussi qu'on parle
alors d'une exposition à ces formidables
doc élu jusqu'en octobre donc faut pas
trop tarder à l'aillet la voix c'est
l'exposition de deux sculpteurs les
lalanne dîner la vente parce que c'était
monsieur et madame qui s'appelait tous
les deux la lan s'appelle ammann lui
s'appelait laval elles sont mariées
oui absolument venu là nan c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de coût que la la le coup de
l'alcool halal alors cédé des sculptures
à la fois ça tient du surréalisme
satire de la mythologie aussi enfin il
ya un rapport un peu étonnant dans
l'introduction de ses oeuvres dans ce
domaine de trianon à versailles
il ya une résonance est extraordinaire
c'est complètement exceptionnel de voir
la corde ans de ses oeuvres d'art
contemporain installée dans ce décor
féerique et bien sûr des jardins de
versailles et de trianon et en même
temps effectivement il ya cet enjeu se
rappelle avec l'utilisation de la
sculpture animalière impôts qui est bien
sûr est très forte chez les lalanne de
deux rappels de vie tels que sous
l'ancien régime
on pouvait découvrir le trianon
aujourd'hui impossible à voir avec des
moutons avec même source il ya des
choses que je suis dans lequel le club
de hockey des oeuvres les plus connues
et la pomme
absolument et c'est un couple alors
c'est parce que là on pas parler
d'argent mais mais mais des oeuvres de
la namsa français s'avouent d'emilio
amplement pour ce rapport justement à la
facilité de lecture en quelque sorte
d'interprétation et que chacun
d'ailleurs peut retravailler en soit
c'est une idée aussi bien c'est pas des
oeuvres figé voilà l'idée c'est que les
gens puissent se les approprier et son
faire l'écho qu'ils souhaitent cesser la
la je pense l'un des vecteurs de la
popularité de ces oeuvres qui
effectivement sont un signe et je crois
que alors cette exposition à la grèce
est de 10 villes une promenade de
catherine pégard président de
l'établissement de versailles et de gens
que ce feu je regagnais mitterrand qui
était le galeriste voilà qui nous a
permis de réaliser ces secteurs
exposition absolument absolument verdure
c'est formidable d'avoir pu en quelques
mois parce que ça s'est réalisé en
quelques mois qu'un atelier dessin
croissance un peu exceptionnel d'avoir
pu réaliser ces répartitions d'oeuvre
danse dans ce magnifique jardin
il y avait que je vous dis cet effet et
émotionnel très fort qui touche tout de
suite les familles des enfants il ya un
rapport à l'oeuvre immédiat qui est
assez étonnant
et on essaie néanmoins de faire aussi
bien sûr qu' aucun abus parce que c'est
là donc c'est oui alors c'est à la fois
c'est vrai que vous avez raison parce
que les enfants c'est faux venus en
famille et en même temps ça ça s'inscrit
dans cette tradition qui a été lancé
depuis quelques semaines maintenant de
l'art contemporain dans les sept
versailles on peut dire qu'on est dans
cette continuité effectivement des
installations puisque le tout le domaine
de trianon on va vivre cet été avec
différentes opérations celles ci étant
bien sûr l'opération majeure mais il y
aura également une exposition photo à la
fin de l'automne
il y aura également une exposition pour
des guides est dédié est organisé par
des publics spécifiques
une association locale qui va permettre
à des artistes handicapés de faire une
exposition
c'est un lieu qui vit très régulièrement
de manière très distinctes et qui est un
vrai point de rencontre pour les jeunes
à foix mais aussi le public en famille
et et intergénérationnel c'est vraiment
un point un lieu à la fois pour le
public de régional mais aussi un public
international grâce à des événements
comme les solutions c'est en cela que
l'art contemporain à versailles est très
intéressant parce qu'il ouvre la porte à
des publics qui n'ont pas forcément
l'idée de venir trouver ce type
d'exposition dans un lieu comme
versailles
d'ailleurs c'est dit on parlait des huit
millions et demi de visiteurs 1-2
traditionnel fer qui dans les années
normales devrait verser mais c'est pas
un seul blu quoi il ya des débuts très
différent celui qui ont des visites très
différentes et des dégoûts alors yale et
à la culture et le jardin yahia bey et
des dizaines de choses à disposition des
préfets et cd public un peu différente
absolument on a une composante de public
qui est à 70% dans les temps ordinaire
composé de visiteurs étrangers suivante
pour cent des visiteurs français 30% sur
1h30 vous vous représentez tout de suite
le chiffre que ça fait c'est très
important
le volume des visiteurs français et et
de là dedans on a des segmentations très
différents c'est sûr
groupe on a des publics d'associations
puisque la société des amis de
versailles blaikie beaucoup de public
régulier mais aussi une carte développé
par par le site lui-même qui s'appelle
un an d'abonnement à versailles et qui
vous permet en deux visites de grandes
zones par exemple l'été d'avoir à sortir
votre carte et en même temps de
poursuivre la découverte culturelle de
ce lieu pendant toute l'année sur
différents événements des rencontres des
débats des visites conférences etc et ça
ouvre le champ également à des avantages
pour découvrir d'autres activités dans
le parc parce que le patient vous c'est
tous les ans la fidélisation du public
la très important la carte tenant à
versailles la carte duo la carte
le solo ses dix neuf mille personnes qui
viennent régulièrement toute l'année
contribuez aussi également par cet
effort la messe à l'entretien du domaine
parce que c'est sa notoriété qui le qui
le pousse à et sa reconnaissance
mais c'est notre rôle si c'est notre
mission de service public de faire
connaître ce lieu à tous les publics
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
soyez vous avez raison nous accueillons
énormément également des publics
éloignés des musées par le tissu
associatif avec des relais culturel et
que nous formons et qui avec des
associations nous amène des publics qui
ne se sentent pas vous pouvoir venir par
eux-mêmes facilement dans un lieu muséal
patrimoniale tels que tel que versailles
faut pas être impressionné par sa rue
saulnier la salle on va trouver quelques
gers il versa c'est pour tout le monde
c'est universel
il faut absolument pouvoir en faire
profiter le plus grand nombre l'épicé
d'autres histoires
alors vous avez pas chômé difficile
compliqué et dot amendes ont comparé des
rénovations
si vous pouvez nous faire visiter le
cabinet privé du roi abba avec plaisir
une belle rencontre vous allez voir on y
va
l'hiver games and you nous sommes là
dans le ce qu'on appelle le cabinet
d'angle du roi absolu non c'est bien ça
cabinet de travail des rois tout à fait
alors c'est pas c'est tout 15 heures
c'est pas le week end
absolument c'est le week-end ce qui fait
installer cette pièce est d'ailleurs le
décor de la pièce elle même vous vous le
montre on est dans une période de
transition du style baroque grandjean
valeurs françaises de louis xiv vers le
style rocaille et vous noté c'est tout
l'intérêt de cette pièce c'est ça qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un décor recueillis
c'est quoi c'est quoi le style rocaille
c'est ce que vous voyez là sur les sur
les boiseries c'est à la guerre c'est
entre filet très feu de de feuillage
très fin très beaucoup plus raffinée
c'est un poste central avec ses figures
de pouty vous regardez également la
frise un que vous avez là on est
vraiment dans le décor but 14 voiliers
avec les couronnes fermer les lauriers
et c'est ça c'est vraiment un style plus
humain plus massif plus plus fort alors
que le style rocaille que vous avez sur
les panneaux et qu'on voit sur les
pièces attenantes
et bien c'est beaucoup plus j'aime où
j'ai rien
avec les graines de fleurs c'est un
style beaucoup plus enlevé on va dire
tout en étant très raffiné donc ce
cabinet d'angle du roi c'est le bureau
louis quand c'est le bureau de le
week-end et en fait on en a le
témoignage
avec cette pièce exceptionnelle un ski
qui fait partie des trésors 1 du
mobilier français et il vient d'être
entièrement restaurée vous retrouvez la
regarde et l'éclat des bronzes dorés des
boiseries qui ornent ce meuble c'est
c'est extraordinaire de le voir je le
voir vivement quand on voit les décors
d'amarante le feuillage sur les les
panneaux ça c'est la restauration qu'il
a permis avant c'etait tres vous voyez
pas un lille parce qu'avec les néo
vernier et malheureusement c'est avec le
temps ça s'était estompé mais comment on
fait d'abord il ya il ya une
organisation qui dépend des budgets
nationaux qui s'occupe d'eux alors tout
à fait à sion ça c'est très fort sur ma
situation exceptionnelle qui est fait
par le c2rmf de l'appellation comme ça
etc re div un peu difficile à comprendre
en fait c'est tout simplement le grand
centre de restauration
ah j'ai oublié france est arrivée des
musées nationaux mobilier français
immobilières français qui permet de
restaurer dans le strict respect bien
sûr les rites hâtif des oeuvres ce
meuble il a été entièrement démontées le
bureau a cédé réouvert toutes les parois
ont été démontées réalisé totalement
restaurée est remontée ensuite jusqu'au
bronze bien sûr qu'on condom voilà
qu'ils ont été entièrement repris je
vous fais combien de corps de métier et
par un jeu je ne voudrais pas rentrer de
free faux nom parce que je faisais ça
existe deux mais effectivement là on a
des bronziers qui sont intervenus on a
des ébénistes derrière on a des
menuisiers pour la carcasse du départ
mais on a aussi des serrurier ferronnier
parce que ce bureau à cylindre comporte
à l'intérieur des mécanismes secrets
qu'il a certainement fallu remettre dans
leur état et c'est une agrégats vous
avez tout à fait raison de se lier de
compétences et de sincère et qui traduit
un tel niveau de qualité de restauration
parce que c'est exceptionnel comme
celle-là on le retrouve tels que tels
que louis cazeneuve et je dis bien toute
la pièce en fait parce que c'est ça est
un peu exceptionnel dans la chance que
nous avons eues avec cette cette période
c'est que tout a été restauré
que ce soit les meubles de goudron que
nous avons là les médaillés que ce soit
les panneaux de salle qui ont été
entièrement démontées entièrement
retraités et reposé absolument là vous
vous êtes dans un cabinet la cheminée
elle même qui a été également reprise de
tout ce que vous voyez là a été
restaurée et c'est ça qui est très rare
dans les restaurations souvent va rendre
les choses à leur parquet wam noble mis
tous ensemble ça en même temps et c'est
ce qui donne cette illusion quand on
prends ton à cette pièce on a le
sentiment que les fournisseurs mais
marchand mercier vienne et les ébénistes
viennent de le livrer roi et elle le lui
font découvrir
c'est ça qui est exceptionnel et que je
souligne qu'en quand j'ai l'opportunité
de faire ce type de visite
parce que c'est rare c'est excessivement
rare d'avoir une harmonie comme ça de
restauration en même temps je pense que
notre mécène rolex a dû être très
enthousiaste à cette idée de pouvoir
créer devait de trouver un mécène
il a bien sûr c'est toujours le gros de
la vague autant nous nous nous vivons de
nos ressources et quand nous avons une
prévenue une fréquentation normale pour
ce qui est des dépenses de l'ordinaire
un quotidien le personnel les charges
d'entretien de maintenance mais par
contre des milliers de restauration ce
exceptionnel tard aujourd'hui n'a plus
les moyens de pouvoir assurer de six
grands projets et ce sont des mécènes
qui nous permette effectivement de les
réaliser alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que le public peut peut veut dire qu'il
ya des visites guidées absolument si on
est organisés l'après-midi jusqu'à
présent on y venait précise alors on dit
nice est vrai qu on y venait sur du sur
des visites conférences cette année son
espace limité
on n'est pas sur la même fréquentation
que le grand appartement 1 4 million et
demi de gens qui parcourait jusqu'en
2019 les grands appartements
ici c'est 250 300 mille personnes
maximum qu'il y ait le parent sur le
principe des visites-conférences
effectivement des vies
l'idée ou des conférenciers des musées
nationaux peuvent présenter différents
aspects et de ces lieux puisqu'on est
dans un appartement avec une trentaine
de pièces où l'on peut évoquer les
différents usages de l'appartement du
collectionneur de louis xiv à son
origine
jusqu'aux appartements aménagés
successivement par louis 15 puis 2016
qui vont apporter des modifications aux
règles de vie et des piquettes qu'avait
est instaurée louis xiv mais qui n'était
plus dont correspondance avec
l'évolution des mentalités et des moeurs
au xviiie siècle est donc bon ce cabinet
dans ce cas il est de votre devoir est
très important dont le fait que le roi
est un bureau à plus grand volume en
biscuit avec deux de ses modernes dont
on a complètement dans sa conception
c'est elle qui est assez exceptionnel
dit aussi qu'un bureau d'aujourd'hui des
bureaux dans nos activités
ces mots qu'il a certainement fait une
pièce comme je vous le disais tout à
fait exceptionnel regardez le travail
d'enquêté de réalisation et les toute
façon on est à une phase qui ne soit pas
travailler très admiratif du travail qui
a été fait justement par tous ces
artisans assez exceptionnel c'est
l'artiste
une volonté que nous que nous avons au
château avec notamment la création à
partir de la rentrée prochaine d'un
campus universitaire sur le château au
campus d'excellence des métiers d'art
nous venons pour tous les cycles de
métier de collège jusqu'au lycée voire
au supérieur présenter ses savoir-faire
ses métiers aux jeunes parce que
beaucoup ne l'ont pas l'idée et ne se
rendent pas compte qu'il ya derrière ces
travaux-là des métiers passionnants à
exercer à réaliser et avec des emplois
en plus et des emplois à la clé
absolument et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce campus est installé locker à
quoi il y aura un congrès pour venir se
renseigner sur absolument il va y avoir
trois trois activités un peu distinctes
d'une part l'information générale
effectivement qui veut qui vient qui va
y être réalisés
et puis ensuite des formations les
formations pour les jeunes qui vont se
dessiner à l'apprentissage à
l'acquisition de ces savoir faire
technique mais aussi à des formations
pour adultes de en reconversion ou des
formations d'accentuation en
professionnel justement sur des
pratiques métier
pointu très fine pour des gens qui ont
déjà des bases mais qui n'ont pas
forcément l'excellence en la matière est
solvable qui souhaite bel et bien sûr il
y aura certainement aussi des visites
découverte pour le public pendant tout
ce qu'il faut faire connaître ses
métiers la france a un vrai potentiel
qui est qui et qui est pas encore
suffisamment utilisées et qui se perd
pour certaines de ces métiers
malheureusement donc il faut absolument
faire mieux connaître tout cela en
particulier aux jeunes c'est combien de
temps cette cette restauration
alors le bureau c'est très difficile où
il prêchait en termes de temps et heure
mais le bureau est parti plus d'un an et
demi au c2rmf pour être restaurées et
cédé bien sûr des centaines d'heures
c'est très difficile de donner un
chiffre mais c'est un an et demi quoi
voilà qui mobilise et alain et demi pour
pour avoir réussi ce challenge
après ce vote c'est exceptionnel et avec
l'ensemble comme on le voit là et
l'ensemble des départs soit vous dites
mais ça c'est pas juste le bureau enfin
le secret de faire cesser cette sécurité
et jusqu'aux fesses que regarder quand
vous regardez vos fenêtres on voyait que
nous avons des fenêtres doré absolument
toutes les pièces maintenant de
l'appartement ont retrouvé leur décor
d'origine
kiki qui est qui qui lui redonne tout
son lustre parce qu'ici on est
véritablement dans l'excellence de la
décoration française du xviiie siècle
venez la voulez vous allez vous prendre
pour louis 15 pour moi quelques noms
quelques instants au moins en tout cas
je l'espère voilà vous allez nous faire
de l'entourage du roi absolument
formidable il ya une autre rénovation ce
qu'on appelle la petite fille mais c'est
ça c'est ça le très récemment nous
venons de le réouvrir le week-end
dernier au public en général alors que
ça venait d'être ouverts précédemment
pour les groupes comme vous l'avez
souligné pour des visites conférences
mais nous avons décidé de le de l'ouvrir
tous les week-ends pour le public en
général pour découvrir un autre une
autre facette de versailles lorsqu on a
tous en tête bien sûr le versailles de
louis xiv et c'est bien au real c'est
une wii qui lui qui l'a lancé mais
derrière cela le château a continué à
vivre après la révolution et c'est ce
que louis philippe en créant le musée
louis fils est-il gay ou fellow voilà
voilà
et en créant ce musée dédié à toutes les
gloires de la france eh bien il a créé
les grandes galeries dans ce qui était
autrefois des appartements de cours pour
la pour la haute noblesse et bien des
ces galeries évoque effectivement toute
l'histoire de france et parmi ces
espaces à l'attique supérieur donc dans
l'aide du midi nous avons la tique
dietschy michel et pourquoi parce que
ces noms des 21 ans justement qui
occupaient ces appartements l'a pressé
de signer et qui a été transformée en un
espace des vocations qui nous permet de
parler nous de la révolution jusqu'à
l'an pire en pire un autre personnage
célèbre de versailles qui n'attendait
que napoléon
alors c'est vrai que c'était le 200e
anniversaire lors apple s'est il ya au
plus haut point on peut envoyer avec
plaisir à l'est
denis verdier manioc nous sommes ici
dans ce qu'on appelle la tique chimay cd
salle napoléon qui sont ouvertes depuis
je crois le 2 juillet le 3 juin
c'est ça tout à fait en fait on est dans
l'ancien appartement après celle de
chine et donc de la famille de chimie
l'entourage immédiat de maria antona oui
c'était une amie marion c'était une amie
et donc du coup on est dans une
continuité puisque là c'est ça ont été
transformés de la volonté de louis
philippe à et la création du musée comme
on le disait tout à l'heure pour en
faire une évocation de toute cette
période de la révolution
d'où la salle dans laquelle je me
trouvais alors là c'est là là on est à
la religion parce que évidemment les
salles vont de la révolution jusqu'à
l'enfer jusqu'à la véritable mans c'est
une collection directoire on est le
premier musée de police de france et ça
c'est complètement méconnu en fait et
sur des aspects différents bien sûr on
pense tous se faisaient la guerre aux
invalides mais là on est sur les parties
guerrière de napoléon nous on a toute la
vie tout la wii des battages toutes les
conquêtes mais aussi toute la vie dans
l'est dans les territoires conquis et
aussi bien sûr à versailles en pendant
donc ici nous sommes dans cette salle de
leur vie à la révolution
avec cette célèbre s qui selon l'avis de
la russie tunis nice vous y voyez on ne
voit que les tec très serviable figurer
mais intéressant parce qu on va tous
travaillent à l'atomic de conception des
oeuvres ne savait pas trop comment elle
allait être représenté finalement ce
n'est pas l'oeuvre qui va être
représentée dans la salle du jeu de
paume que vous habite par ailleurs à
découvrir aussi la salle du rayon bleu
qui est en cours de restauration par les
travaux est actuellement en cours de
restauration
elle va là aussi retrouvé tout son
aspect d'origine dc additionnant environ
et donc les autres oeuvres que nous
avons dans cette salle évoque la prise
de la bastille bien sûr les les grands
courants de bataille de la période
révolutionnaire et jusqu'aux personnes
de célèbres bien sûr robespierre danton
c'est juste des critères tout l'exemple
figure de quelqu'un figure de révolution
absolue puissions va par là apparaît
dans ces salles qui ont été restaurées
récemment alors on se trouve ici dans
les salles c c'est le général bonaparte
à à totalement vont vous on est passé de
la période de purement révolutionnaire
aux premières oeuvres qu'on a vu avec
quelle jeune véritable hauts de gironde
et devait très belle oeuvre ici on
rentre véritablement dans la période de
campagne de du général bonaparte qui sur
ordre va partir à la conquête à la fois
de l'italie et nous allons les
progressivement jusqu'à l'egypte jusqu'à
l'éjecter de campagne qui ont fait ça sa
réputation et qui vont quelque part
asseoir sa future carrière
c'est le début de valeur dès le début de
bonaparte qui va faire généralissime de
la période consulaires avant de devenir
lui-même premier consul c'est ça donc là
c'est la campagne d'italie
oui on est d'abord sur ses premières
scènes de la campagne italie avec les
passages à milan et puis l'arrivée sur
bourdiaux le la continuité ensuite sur
la descente italienne il ya ça se fait
en deux temps il
il fait une première partie de conquête
il revient il repart ccc dans notre
histoire aujourd'hui on ne sait pas une
coquette une hymne national signé sa 9e
en scène le plus compliqué que ça et ici
à cette continuité justement par les
tableaux que vous voyez des différentes
phases de cette conquête qui se déroule
jusqu à l'egypte donc que l'on connaît
avec les retours au verso des
collections dans les collections
nationales françaises aujourd'hui un
d'oeuvre du cube par an maintenant que
je suis
oui oui de nos qui a récupéré qu'à
récupérer beaucoup de trésors mais c'est
aussi ça qui a construit cette époque
oui c'est ce que je voulais vous donner
les chances que le pôle éolien
d'estinnes la guerre il ya ces tableaux
qui sourdait des oeuvres remarquables
mais qui sont aussi un peu d'une façon
de manière de communication ou
communication politique complètement on
a un communicant hors pair en la
personne de napoléon et son entourage il
va instrumentaliser tout ce qu'il fait
au service de sa promotion et de sa
destinée de sa gloire absolument il
pense déjà réussi on pense qu'ils le
pensaient sharks il établit déjà il
savait pas forcément peut-être à fond et
que ça les véritables manquent pas mais
en tout cas il se dirigeait vers vers
des postes de pouvoir important assez
clair et après laurent continue et
ensuite on continue avec la prise
d'aboutir un tableau qui évoque cette
période de conquête à vers l'egypte
par étapes successives egypte l'egypte
est ici et nous la retrouvons également
dans la pièce suivante
on est dans la dernière salle de cet
article chimie c'est sarah polley diane
et donc on a eu des batailles c'est à
dire la construction voilà de la figure
politique la police et je peux dire et
qui se termine alors rions alors pire
après bien sûr mais qui se termine par
le directoire et la voilà cette période
consulaires on envoie envoie l'assemblée
consulaire où on voit le premier consul
qui siègent key2key devenu un peu lyon
on l'a également ici en pied et dans
cette pièce toujours avec des évocations
à la fois ici le port d'anvers de
l'autre côté les batailles du jour avec
le jeune on est dans ce mixte de venir
on est dans l'instauration d'un régime
et qui était pas une mesure facile à
mettre en oeuvre
et puis les salles après continue
effectivement leur développement après
la période consulaire on va vers l'
empire et on a le reste de l'aide du
midi où les salles se déploie autour
d'eux des représentations en portrait de
la famille impériale et des grandes
marées chaud sur toute une galerie
jusque la fin des représentations avec
le célèbre la célèbre statue devait la
main de napoléon âgées après l'exil et
on finit cette période là plus rien à
versailles sur la touche tricolore était
de l'esf intérêt à napoléon
mais c'est vrai que enfin c'est pas tout
à fait la même chose s'est passé c'est
pas la même pub et l'on note presse une
préfiguration avec ce tableau du
couronnement à ses babines
non c'est vrai vous avez ça peut y faire
penser vous avez raison quand on connaît
les deux destinations et ça me fait
d'ailleurs l'occasion de dire que
napoléon et et ailleurs dans le château
bien sûr parce que là on fait c'est
cette pièce qui viennent d'être
restaurés mais on trouve napoléon à la
fois dans la galerie des batailles
avec les grandes batailles victorieuses
et bien sûr et on le trouve également
sur toutes les lèvres du midi au
rez-de-chaussée là c'est ouvert tous les
jours alors qu'ici il me semble ouverte
que les vélos il ya vingt ans je disais
n'est ce pas elle doit au rez de
chaussée on retrouve c'était cette
épopée dans tous les domaines et évoquer
avec toutes les grandes batailles qui
est qu'il a réalisé et ça ça montre à
quel point le musée consacre une place
très importante à cette période
napoléonienne tel que l'a voulu le
philippe pour évoquer cette histoire de
ce tour de france alors un mot pour
terminer je te pousse sur les relations
napoléon et de versailles alors c'est
vrai c'est ambigu puisque il s'installe
à trianon fait le siège de lancer leur
saison à ces régimes donc c'est très
difficile c'est une image du livre très
difficile à a instrumentalisé pour
convier de le dire pour un homme qui a
très bien su communiquer et théâtralisée
son règne un peu à l'instar de ce
qu'avait fait louis xiv en son temps
avec d'autres valeurs d'autres principes
et bien napoléon s'installe au trianon
effectivement la seconde à perdre 10
marie louise va occuper la maison de la
reine et va occuper également les
appartements dans le petit trianon et
finalement napoléon avait un projet
d'aménagement de delhaize du midi du sud
sur le court central du château pas à
laitages louis 14 ans donc on réduisait
en rez-de-jardin nous avons tous les
décors qui pourrait être installé
tout ça est roulé et tout ça est prêt à
être assailli ne l'a jamais été parce
que malheureusement lempire s'est
achevée avant que napoléon n'ai pu faire
réaliser ces travaux et donc il n'a
finalement jamais occupé officiellement
versailles mais là en tout cas bien
connu et bien bien pratique et je crois
que dans l'est on va aller voir
l'exposition avec elisabeth maisonnier
qui avait comme hélas le commissaire un
commissaire et je crois dans cet essai
sur les dessins absolument versa et je
crois qu'on voit d'ailleurs les projets
dans ses dessins que été fait pour
napoléon pour son aménagement aversa
rien absolument c'est ce que je vais
vous laisser découvrir avec plaisir
c'est une très jolie exposition
effectivement de dessins qui traite
également d'ailleurs ce qu'on a évoqué
des métiers des dés de la vie
quotidienne vous allez le voir je vous
laisse les comices tout cela avec madame
maisonnier merci infiniment
avec plaisir alors nous sommes dans les
appartements de madame de maintenon avec
four en janvier vous êtes la commissaire
de l'exposition dessins pour versailles
qu'on peut voir jusqu'au 3 octobre
n'oubliez pas aller vite parce qu'elle
est formidable cette explosion comment
vous avez réuni au fond ce dessin qui
était assez méconnue alors ils sont plus
qu assez méconnu puisque comme très
méconnue bien fragile
ça n'est quasiment jamais exposés ou en
tout cas uniquement à l'occasion
d'expositions temporaires
donc là c'est là l'occasion de découvrir
tout un ensemble qui a été acheté entre
l'an 2000 et l'année 2020 et 20 ans
d'acquisitions 20 ans d'acquisitions
voilà et qui montrent en fait une belle
cohérence dans les thématiques
une grande variété de techniques et une
grande amplitude chronologique mais on
va du 17e au 20e siècle on va de 1660 à
1920 voilà c'est ça qui serait pas
versailles une grande diversité et c'est
vrai qu'on peut les voir ses dessins de
plusieurs manières
il ya évidemment la qualité artistique
de certains d'entre eux et puis il ya la
dimension historique et qui me
tout à fait la dimension historique elle
est évidente c'est ce qui guide beaucoup
nos choix puisque c'est ça doit toujours
être en lien avec versailles avec son
histoire mais la dimension artistique
elle arrive de façon parfois
complètement miraculeuse les dessins
préparatoires pour le plafond des reculs
ce sont des véritables chefs-d'oeuvre
les pastels pastel de le brun c'est
d'une grande qualité esthétique et c'est
un moment marquant dans l'histoire de
l'art
nos projets architecturaux pour une re
création de versailles ce sont aussi des
chefs-d'oeuvre de du dessin
d'architecturé
donc en plus une grande variété et quoi
s'appuie d'ailleurs oui alors à tout à
l'heure
on aurait pu voir ce que ce qu'on aurait
pu devenir versailles
oui et même ce à quoi on échapper soit
appelée parfois vous parlez pas ce thème
justement là c'est le plus ancien celui
là alors les portraits toute cette série
de pastels donc notamment ce très joli
portrait de louis xiv louis xiv tout
jeune homme
c'est un portrait qui représentait sur
le vif donc c'est on a vraiment l'image
de ce jeune homme au moment de son
mariage en 1660 qui est très méconnue
puisque surtout à versailles on montre
roi de gloire le roi soleil est là on a
ce jeune homme qui a quand même déjà un
regard très direct très autoritaire mais
qui reste voilà un tout jeune homme qui
va épouser donc marie thérèse
et est représentée également en sa mère
anne d'autriche et on est sur quelque
chose
des oeuvres qui sont importantes pour
l'histoire du pastel en france puisque
le le l'artiste ces valeureux vaillance
et or l'artiste et vallerand vaillance
et un artiste originaire de l'île qui
exerce à amsterdam
c'est un inventeur c'est un innovateur
en dans l'histoire de l'art c'est lui
qui va développer la technique du pastel
qui recouvre comme vous le voyez toute
la feuille donc une technique de pastel
qui se rapproche de la peinture avec ce
ce bâton de pastel ce bâton de couleur
et sa longueur
c'est le pastel en couleurs extracteur
tout à fait et il invente avec cette
série puisqu'il est invité en france
pour réaliser cette série consacrée aux
principaux invités du mariage de louis
xiv dont il ya d'autres prônent et 370
pourtant on est en c160 ce sens sont
exactement celles 160 donc c'est le
premier le premier dessin c'est la
célèbre le plus ancien au seul c'est
l'oeuvre par dont la plus ancienne de
cette exposition
alors celle là elle est assez
extraordinaire parce que ben voilà on va
le dire aux enfants la connaissent
bouzou c'est charles perrault c'est
charles perrault alors et il n'a pas
encore écrit les comptes puisqu'il écrit
les comptes plutôt à la fin de sa vie et
là c'est celle hommes de colbert c'est
celui qui invente
le décor de versailles le décor
allégoriques et et c'est le grand ami le
grand complice en quelque sorte de
charles le brun qu'il dessine le brun et
c'est un dessin de charles le brun et
charles le brun et économe de pastel là
on en connaît à peine une vingtaine et
il réserve vraiment ses dessins assez
proche au roi mais aussi à ses proches
et se passe-t-elle est un est un
portrait d'amitié entre deux hommes qui
s'estiment qui s'apprécient et qui
faisait partie de la collection
personnelle de le brun puisqu'il 2 et
qui faisait partie de la collection
personnelle de charles perrault
puisqu'on le trouve dans son inventaire
donc une oeuvre précieuse précieuse pour
le brandir d'eau de mots de lebrun pour
pour s'occuper à bas le brun ici c'est
l'artiste c'est le créateur de la
galerie des glaces de val d'or du
plafond de la galerie des glaces est un
des grands acteurs des grands décors de
versailles et de très nombreux décors de
la fin du xviie
alors on va continuer un petit peu cette
exposition
[Musique]
il est ça va être des zones où nous
sommes devant cette horde de françois
lemoine qui constitue l'affiché de
l'exposition
alors je vous laisse vous en parler
alors c'est vrai que c'est sans doute le
chef-d'oeuvre
vous parliez de différences artistiques
historiques là on a les dimensions les
deux dimensions qui se rejoignent et on
est sûr certainement l'un des plus beaux
bastel de la première moitié du xviiie
siècle ou vraiment lemoine est un très
grand pastelliste
il réalise des pour ce plafond du salon
d'hercule qui compte 140 de figure il
réalise une esquisse de chacune des
figures et pour les personnages les plus
importants des têtes au pastel comme
s'il réalisait en quelque sorte des
portraits pour ses figures essentielles
là on a l'amour de la vertu l'amour de
la vertu qui élève l'homme au dessus de
lui même et quillan entraîne donc
hercules vers jupiter qui va lui donner
la main db la déesse de la jeunesse et
le faire accéder à l'immortalité au
moulin peut on à ce jeune homme qui
d'ailleurs est à mon avis plus beau que
la peinture même si le moine est un très
grand peintre et qui exprime à la fois
une grande détermination et une grande
douceur
dans dans le regard dans la façon dont
ils tournent ils tournent la tête et
techniquement on a vraiment une très
grande maîtrise du pastel par le moine
avec le laisses ton sur l'épaule les
hachures sur le sur le coup très légère
au niveau de la mâchoire et puis c'est
rehauts de blanc qui lui donne
voilà toute cette douceur et se traîne
noire qui entoure le portrait et qui lui
donne toute cette présence qu'elle était
du dessin du pastel évidemment alors
c'est une ce qu'il y ait beaucoup de ce
qui sort de cette exposition
forcément c'est une composition deux et
on a une effectivement une petite
section de dessins préparatoires qui
donne une image du travail incroyable
réalisé pour les artistes qui ont
contribué à versailles depuis les tout
premiers on a le dessin de la première
chambre de louis xiv un dessin
préparatoire pour le salon diane un
dessin préparatoire pour la chambre de
marylise 15 cas pour le salon des nobles
de marie antoinette et même un dessin
pour les salles du maroc
commandé par louis philippe j'aimerais
d'un petit bonhomme c'est donc cédé sur
20 ans de division ou est ce qu'ils
étaient c'est toujours la grande
difficulté ils passent en vente aux
enchères où ils passent entre les mains
des marchands évidemment il était en
collection particulière ce soir avant et
par contre c'est un tout petit peu
difficile de les pister avant leur
passage en vente
d'accord alors on va continuer la visite
si vous êtes d'accord
tout à fait je vous emmène
[Musique]
désolé ici on va feuilleté au full album
de marie antoinette
exactement c'est l'album qu'elle a fait
réaliser pour garder en mémoire garder
la trace du jardin anglais qu'elle fait
construire qu'elle fait concevoir par
son architecte richard mique inspiré de
cette vogue pour les jardins
anglo-chinois avec toutes sortes de
fabrique
parfois très exotique comme ce jeu de
bagues chiha décor chinois qu'elle fait
installer tout à côté du du château du
petit trianon alors faut bien s'imaginer
que c'est une très jeune femme il ya le
côté il ya le côté ludique bien sûr
puisqu'on a un manège entouré d'une
galerie pour que les spectateurs
puissent assister à ces joutes en
quelque sorte
voilà sous préfet ce divertissement
c'est un divertissement après ça les
autres construction du jardin anglais
chinois sont plus des aménagements de la
nature on à la création du rocher la
création de la grotte et de très belles
constructions
dans l'esprit très élégant du xviiie
siècle le temple de l'amour
le belvédère avec leur très grand
raffinement
voilà ce moment' perfection aussi
qu'elle installe dans les jardins avec
beaucoup de goût beaucoup trouvent avec
comble oui parce qu'elle est elle à
l'origine pour de tout ça
marie-antoinette mais les femmes qui
suit la mode elle aime la mode et elle
aime la mode dans les jardins également
donc l aile suisse est cette mode que de
nombreux grands seigneurs mettre en
oeuvre dans leur dans leur château mais
avec beaucoup plus de finesse de goût de
délicatesse beaucoup moins d'exubérance
et parfois le mélange de tout ça qui
crée ainsi un certain mauvais goût voilà
ici on a exactement tout à fait alors on
est dans les années 1780 un petit peu
avant la révolution
le il faut savoir que le château de
versailles à cette époque là ils portent
très bon état je crois qu'on peut même
dire que c'est une ruine c'est pas ça en
tout cas pour pour la pour ce qui
concerne la façade du côté de lille une
partie de la façade
conçu par louis xiv est en très mauvais
état mais métayer et elle est
complètement déséquilibrée par la
construction de la halle et gabriel
voulue par le 15
donc on a d'un côté un pavillon en
pierre
à colonnes très élevé et de l'autre côté
une construction de la façade qui reste
assez assez basses et le jugement des
contemporains c'est que tout ça manque
considérablement de majesté et n'est pas
digne du palais darrois bon c'est plus
ça pour wim impression que c'est
toujours restée la même chose versailles
pas du tout enfin et alors il ya
évidemment des projets de rénovation qui
se font jour on peut voir tous ces
dessins de rénovation dans les années
1780 il faut se poursuivre jusqu'à
napoléon
oui tout à fait les deux architectes que
napoléon charge de lui proposer des
plans pour versailles récupère en fait
des grands projets parfois complètement
utopique
réalisé par les architectes de louis
saez
on a échappé à un versailles à la
manière de saint pierre de rome avec un
grand péristyle
devant on a échappé à un bâtiment avec
un immense escalier qui mène au niveau
de la galerie des glaces voilà on a
échappé à des choses parfois un petit
peu terrifiante les projets vers le
bourg humour mais est finalement vous
disiez il y avait sept désharmonie si je
peux dire dans les 780 ça a été corrigée
ou pas c'est corrigé simplement sous la
restauration ou louis xviii et s'est
achevée par le chili aps
reconstruit une aile parallèle est
identique à l'ale gabriel pour au moins
donner une certaine symétrie à la façade
du côté de la ville mais on ne va pas du
tout vers les grands projets voulus par
louis cells et ensuite napoléon de
reconstruire totalement la façade c'est
quand même il ya toujours eu dans
l'histoire le fait du prince sur au fond
la possibilité de faire des faire
construire des choses qui leur plaisait
quoi alors c'est une donnée historique
tout à fait on suit aussi la mode après
ça il ya le réalisme via le réalisme
économique quand il ya plus d'argent on
ne mène pas leur changer quand il y à
des guerres on consacre son énergie à
autre chose donc il faut des conditions
bien bien particulière pour qu'on puisse
se lancer dans des projets
architecturaux aussi aussi face et aussi
le oui c'est vrai et c'est vrai que il
pas toujours merci infiniment elizabeth
beisel et donc cette exposition c'est
jusqu'où 3 octobre
courez-y parce que c'est des dessins
voilà si vous ne les avez jamais vus
vous ne verrez peut-être plus après je
ne sais pas ou en tout cas de plus
difficilement
merci infiniment je vous en prie
[Musique]
le rob renner bonjour bonjour c'est le
directeur de versailles spectacles et
directeur de l'opéra de versailles
nous sommes là dans cette salle sublime
justement il y avait les 250 ans de
l'opéra de versailles c'était en 2020 ce
qui ont été un peu perturbé par la crise
sanitaire
mais vous n'êtes pas rester inactifs au
delà pendant cette période il ya
notamment alors on peut retrouver la
discographie
versailles spectacles oui on se dit que
on avait deux possibilités alors face à
l'impossibilité d'accueillir du public
là encore c'était soit de payer les gens
à rien faire chez eux ça s'appelle le
chômage partiel soit de leur dire vous
venez quand même au lieu de faire le
concert on en fait l'enregistrement pour
faire un cd ou et la captation pour en
faire un produit vidéo que d'autres gens
pourront voir et ainsi on a fait plus de
cinq mille cinq cents jours de travail
pour des artistes sur cette durée
finalement assez longue et un million en
or public et je crois que c'était très
bien parce que d'abord ça permettra à
des gens qui nous faisons ne sont pas
venus de découvrir d'ici mai deux aussi
de très très loin twins et adresse est
logique sur les fadettes de l'opéra de
paris mais aussi aux gens qui vont le
découvrir
oui de manière plus large là soudain ça
donne une autre possibilité de devenir
entre guillemets virtuellement à
versailles pour écouter de la musique et
puis on a découvert plein de répertoire
qu'on n'était pas obligatoirement en
train de se dire on va les
enregistrements s'est dit bon faut le
faire maintenant c'est l'occasion
et puis on a fait vivre des gens et ça
c'est important pour les musiciens pour
les chanteurs notamment croire qu'on va
être chez soi à la maison qu'on va
répéter tous les jours s'il ya aucun
concert pendant un an
ça marche pas donc on a vu chacun que
faire le potager sava certain temps puis
on l'a parfait le deuxième choix souvent
visiblement donc là l'idée est un peu la
même dans l'autre sens plutôt que de ne
rien faire chez soi
certes payé par des aides qui sont
uniques au monde 1 on dit pas assez mais
c'est vraiment un cas exceptionnel
notamment pour les artistes et pour
beaucoup de professions néanmoins les
muses
voilà c'est mieux si on peut faire
quelque chose vraiment donc à la
discographie avec évidemment il ya
notamment cette création the ghost of
versailles le fantôme de versailles créé
alors très peu de temps oui les fantômes
de versailles qui est un opéra case
quasiment 30 ans qui était commandé pour
le metropolitan opera à new york mais on
a enfin présenté en france puisqu'il
parle que d'ici et ça se déroule ici
avec plus ou moins des fantômes de alors
de marionnettes par exemple et de vos
marchés mais enfin cette année on a eu
des fantômes toute façon je connais
public alors c'était raccord mais on a
aussi enregistré les quatre saisons
li est celle d'un compositeur italien
qui était à la cour de france we do à
l'époque et qui les a fait un peu le
même style mais à versailles où beaucoup
d'autres musiques des motets de rimbaud
né à william une collection aussi de la
chambre du roi beaucoup de ses
semblables qu'on crée forcément et et
puis donc ce que vous disiez c'est à
dire ceux ce streaming quoi celle là il
vaut opéra à ça oui une plateforme sur
laquelle on peut qui s'appelle live tiré
opéra bersani
on peut regarder alors on peut regarder
directement on peut télécharger le sont
décédés bref on peut prendre en compte
numériquement toute cette production
d'imagés de sons et en profite et passe
partout
ouais ça c'est promis la bri de chez soi
où l'on télécharge et voilà on peut être
à l'opéra quand pratiquement c'est dans
l'air du temps iliad il ya de l'opéra et
de la danse aussi un gars de l'opéra
yalda lance du concert il n'y a pas que
des trucs baroque rien par exemple la
symphonie fantastique de berlioz par
exemple donc des choses un peu de vin
qui sont le bon portrait de ce que nous
faisons ici régulièrement pour un public
qui est je crois est devenu de plus en
plus nombreux qui ont fait être de 150
ans même si c'est un peu un anniversaire
on n'a pas eu le temps de souffler tout
les mails de vous aimer mais en même
temps bon là on continue on va dire il
ya eu un il y avait un coup de vent sur
les bougies ont les rallumer on
recommence oui on a l'impression que au
fond cette période qui est évidemment
extrêmement difficile quand on est quand
on est responsable de ce spectacle
justement ou dans nos peurs vous avez
profité un peu pour vous réinventer un
peu enfin ou inventer d'autres d'autres
formes de de communication de la culture
oui on en a finalement on a été au pied
du mur pour aller plus vite vers ce qui
est une évolution logique le spectacle
vivant restera une chose en soi qu'il
faut venir voir et écouter en vrai parce
que c'est une expérience alors que si
j'ai une vidéo je peut l'arrêter quand
je veux alors le spectacle s'arrête pas
quand je veux ça fait une différence va
moi si je peut l'arrêter mais le public
peut moi et ça ça restera une vérité
c'est j'ai à dire c'est comme tremper
les pieds dans l'eau froide bon bah ça
c'est une expérience que la vidéo ne me
donnera jamais c'est pas fait pour ça
par contre pouvoir produire autrement
pouvoir on va dire décalé dans le temps
et dans l'espace ces aspects artistiques
ça permet de toucher plus
public de le toucher autrement aussi
avec le sous titre dans une autre langue
ou dans des durées différentes soudain
je peux en consommer que cinq minutes
alors que présente la jeune génération
veut dire écoutez 2h30 d'opéra et c'est
l immense alors qu'on écoutait un bout
de cinq minutes finalement c'est facile
et ça ce sont d'autres manières de faire
et je crois qu'elles sont un petit peu
comme l'invention du 10 qui a presque un
siècle maintenant elles sont des
révolutions favorables elles n'ont
jamais vider les salles de concert par
les deux vont ensemble et pour les
artistes évidemment c'était une
possibilité de s'exprimer pendant cette
période difficile alors il va y voir la
saison nouvelle qui commence en octobre
ce soir avec richard coeur de lion
oui un opéra don très lié à l'histoire
de france bien sûr mais notre adversaire
puisque c'est les la musique de richard
coeur de lion le grand air au richard
aumont roi est le dernier à avoir
ressenti ici sous l'ancien régime est
même tellement retenti que ça a fait
fermer entre guillemets l'opéra de
versailles puisque le roi et la reine
ont été accusés de fomenter de lentilles
révolution et c'est ça qui a causé
littéralement l'invasion du château de
jeux plus tard et le départ de la
famille royale d'un château où ils ne
sont plus jamais revenus qui est fermée
qui depuis est devenu maintenant un
musée mais n'a plus jamais été une
résidence entre guillemets princesse et
c'est cet opéra qui déclenche sa a
littéralement 8c cet air de musique que
les officiers réunis dans cet opéra
chante quand le roi vient les saluer qui
va être rapportées tout de suite à paris
passe il ya toujours des bonnes âmes
pour new york
ce qui s'est passé et à paris on fait un
scandale commence à ses terres au
richard aumont roi c'est donc un air a
entre guillemets à nîmes dans la
monarchie c'est inadmissible alors ce
sont les officiers du roi y ait une
cohérence et ça va enflammer les
parisiens ou plutôt les parisiens
puisque ce sont elles qui vont envahir
versailles deux jours plus tard et en ce
mois d'octobre 1789 la famille royale on
va dire acculé par le peuple qui tire ça
y est me revient plus
donc ça sera le premier il ya aussi des
très beaux spectacles de danse et aurait
vu dans des décors et galerie de presse
locale ça voilà angelin prejlocaj va
produire ici pour noël les fêtes de noël
sa magnifique version du lac des cygnes
je crois que c'est à la fois la musique
de tchaïkovski qui est somptueuse et
puis la danse très particulière de près
le jeune âge qui mélange très bien le
classique des classiques et les culs ce
qu'on aime dans le classique les grandes
les grands groupes à 20 personnes plutôt
défi d'ailleurs puisque ce sont des
signaux l'histoire mais aussi les
garçons je pense peut-être pour jouer
les mines même champ petit canard et
puis il ya toutes ces robes qui
ressemble à des tutus mais qui n'en sont
pas tout à fait ce très habile et puis
des moments très contemporain entre
guillemets plus d'aujourd'hui par
tellement contemporain qui viennent met
du sel dans cette histoire ça fait un
ballet étonnant qui a un succès fou pas
c'est typiquement pour nos fêtes de noël
et puis alors 2022
il ya des élections présidentielles mais
il ya aussi essayé de me divertir de la
naissance de molière voilà alors molière
bon ben il a écrit beaucoup de choses
qui pourraient tout à fait fonctionner
avec dédain souliers avant ça y est
évidemment je sais pas si c'est un plus
le misanthrope art naïf ou l'école des
femmes est un exemple mais nous
proposerons le malade imaginaire
voilà le malade imaginaire dans la
production de la comédie française avec
guillaume gilbert guillaume gallienne
notamment voilà en gros un quart de la
saison prochaine ce sera au tour de
molière dont l'importance a été moins à
versailles d'ailleurs il est un peu mort
avant l'heure mais il dira l'éclosion
mail de même ça rien il y a connu la
fédé fait dans les jardins mais en tout
cas molière a une place très importante
dans l'époque entre guillemets louis xiv
et il est peut-être pour les france est
aujourd'hui le symbole théâtrale si on
devait retenir qu'un auteur de théâtre
lui tout le monde connaît voilà avec des
pièces dont chacun connaît au moins le
titre
donc on présentera et le malade
imaginaire avec guillaume gallienne et
d'épicés de la musique aussi
alors et c'est comme ça beaucoup de
comédies ballets c'est le cas du malade
imaginaire c'est le cas du bourgeois
gentilhomme et que nous montrerons à
nouveau après
après plusieurs déjà présentation de la
milesse dans la mise en scène de denis
podalydès et puis nous finirons avec
george dandin jettent une pièce moins
connus mais aussi brillante avec là
aussi de la musique et je crois que ça
fera un bel ensemble et puis des
concerts les musiques 18 janvier les
comédies tout le travail de molière et
c'est vraiment très impressionnant
on sait pas assez mais molière était un
proche du roi ils étaient plus âgés que
lui pas mollir était plus âgé que le roi
mais son père le père de manière avait
une charge de vallet tapissier 7 le
matin en gros il faisait le lit du roi
et quand le père ne pouvait passer le
fils donc il ya une proximité une espèce
de chose près ce que on va dire aux
musiques enfin voilà du matin qui fait
que molière à étaient bien connus du roi
c'est sans doute ça qui lui a fait cette
protection royale au point de pouvoir
jouer des pièces autorisé par la cour
alors qu'elle était interdite partout où
il y avait un croisement de dévoués de
jean compliqué pour empêcher que ça se
passe je crois que molière et la
représentation du temps de louis xiv
peut-être là la plus éclatante et puis
pour nous aujourd'hui ce sont des tests
d'une grande facilité d'accès et d'une
belle langue
donc c'est vraiment là un ça
donne envie et puis existent aux îles ce
mariage entre la langue et la musique
qui vise à évidemment alors reparler
aussi d'aider des spectacles parce que
il ya cet été bah beaucoup de
possibilités de venir lui ni à
versailles il ya notamment les grandes
eaux alors les grandes zones en a et en
journée qu'ils appellent les grandes où
les vendeurs qui sont la chose la plus
traditionnelle qui sont depuis 350 ans
en place puisque un peu plus de 350 même
nom puis s'est littéralement lui 14 qui
bien sûr décide d'implanter ce réseau de
fontaine exceptionnelle dans le jardin
de versailles
ça va représenter un tiers des dépenses
de construction du château la partie
uniquement
on va dire de l'eau et des fontaines se
sait absolument extraordinaire avec
quasiment toute la région au dessus de
versailles tout le plateau de saclay de
satory de saint cyr est vraiment
reconstituée avec des rigoles pour
amener l'eau amener l'eau à vélo dans
une ville où il n'y a pas de rivière
versailles et pour faire ce grand canal
cette pièce d'eau des suisses et tout le
système de conduite de l'eau et qui en
fait à l'époque un endroit unique au
monde sur ce nombre de fontaines et des
l'époque on visite et le roi fait
lui-même un guide
une manière de montrer les jardins
versailles c'est lui qui fait le guide
dans un texte
donc on s'est inspiré de sa bien sûr
pour redonner à toutes ces fontaines
leur chance historique
il est plein et puis c'est une manière
pour le public de visiter un jardin de
plein air extraordinaire mais c'est
aussi un musée de plein air avec des
statuts partout larchitecture de du
château d'eau sans pour autant avoir
rien besoin de connaître ce qu'on peut
venir en fait un peu on admire c'est
très très bon c'est magnifique c'est
beau on se promène et en plus on était
souvent il fait beau et profiter et en
soirée on propose avec les grandes eaux
nocturnes finalement le même format sur
la surface mais de travailler avec aussi
de la lumière avec quelquefois des
choses complémentaires ont fait la
sérénade dans la galerie des glaces
juste avant de 18h30 à 20h30 bon on peut
littéralement parcours et les plus beaux
si le personnel du château tous les
samedis jusqu'à fin septembre
et on peut pas re et des plus belles
salles du château avec des musiciens des
danseurs et à la fin de sa bien sûr il
ya les grandes eaux nocturnes et qui se
termine par un feu d'artifice classé la
belle mère l'a poussé versailles parce
que c'était l'idée de ces grandes fêtes
qui n'était pas fermée au public un il y
avait 10 millions voilà tout ce qu'on
peut dire c'est assez alors se rend pas
compte aujourd'hui on arrivé là couvre
tout ça mais voilà vous pouvez vous dire
vous pouvez parfois avoir le droit voilà
c'est un monument national avec ses
jardins ses spectacles il faut savoir
leur donner à un public
alors certes l'entrée par gratuite ça
c'est autre chose mais c'est pas
réservés kim à une chose dont je suis
exclu
c'est une chose dont finalement je peux
entre guillemets profiter historiquement
ces mots aussi bien que d'aller au
cinéma ou et ça vraiment je crois que
c'est important
et le public est très en demande de ça
ils adorent le patrimoine de plus en
plus surtout quand il est bien entretenu
et je pense que les franciliens souvent
le samedi soit on fait quoi c'est une
occasion en or voilà une occasion à
porter entre guillemets budgétaire c'est
pas cher
artistiquement c'est très c'est très
chaleureux le feu d'artifice à la fin et
en même temps c'est pas ça ne nécessite
aucune spécificité de préparation de
connaissances je peux ne pas avoir lu
bien voilà c'est vraiment que les facile
on peut juste regardé et on l'a fait
deux éditions spéciales justement 10
bars dont on dit samedi où il y aura le
15 août c'est alors voilà on fait le 15
août une nocturne particulière ce n'est
pas un samedi
simplement on a décidé pour le 15 août
qui est traditionnellement en france une
date de feu delà de deux feux entre
guillemets alors vous savez pour
lesquelles ça dépend où mais il ya
souvent du feu d'artifice et on s'est
dit que c'était l'occasion de faire
cette soirée là beaucoup moins d'eau et
beaucoup plus de feu alors pas tellement
plus long le feu d'artifice parce que
déjà il fait 20 minutes c'est pas mal
mais toute la soirée d'avoir des
éléments avec du fun donc d'éclairer le
tout tout ce jardin avec des bougies
d'avoir des entre guillemets jongleurs
de feu des cracheurs de feu donc d'avoir
la présence du feu et de la lumière
beaucoup plus que d'habitude sur une
seule soirée celle du 15 août
et puis le 25 septembre l'année dernière
on se dit que c'était bien de faire
peut-être à l'essai versailles et louis
xiv
un peu comme emmanuel macron a récemment
fait la fête de la musique et de la
musique électro chez lui enfin ça
c'était mes musiciens
ça sera les mêmes musiciens c'est les
mêmes c'est les mêmes c'est les
musiciens du label ed banger qui au lieu
de le faire à l'elysée pour happy few
parce que l'accord était petit vont
faire les grandes eaux nocturnes dans
l'espace de louis xiv mais avec du son
électro un signal en tout cas ça peut
auprès d'un autre pub les seins c'est
non mais ça ça mélange tout en
respectant pas ce que la musique électro
c'est pas ils se tapent pas dessus et dr
les barres de fer donc c'est pas du tout
ça ça reste très respectueux et en même
temps soudas ça donne une modernité
mais c'est vrai que vous avez raison
d'insister ya contrôle du public de
versailles à plusieurs publics en
réalité c'est bien sûr et plusieurs
attraits il ya celui qui aime l'histoire
et celui là il est on va dire souvent
assez âgées et puis à un public très
jeune qui vient avec l'école est souvent
on perd le public versailles et enfin le
public du château de versailles on le
perd de la fin de la période scolaire
jusqu'à six reviennent avec leur
rendement donc souvent les pères sur 20
ans et ben là soudain la musique électro
qui est plus pour un public qui a entre
20 et 40 s'est parfaitement cette cible
et ceux là vont venir sans les enfants
puisqu'ils n'ont pas encore souvent mais
ça va être l'occasion pour eux de
s'approprier versailles louis xiv était
un roi jeunes fondamentalement on voit
toujours les gens vieux parce qu'ils
sont mort vieux est normal et morieux
mais lui il était jeune et quand
versailles était à sa floraison il y
aurait une quarantaine d'années ici il y
avait la fête les artistes partout et
les artistes de son temps la modernité
l'avant garde
il l'a promu alors on va pas faire
exactement la même chose mais en faisant
cela on est dans notre temps et c'est ce
qui l'a été avant tout oui c'est ça
quand on prône son époque de jeu et
c'est ça qui donne une dynamique et
qu'il va trouver un autre public parce
que même si on peut dire versailles a
beaucoup de visiteurs on voit en ce
moment qui a moins 80 % de visiteurs
parce que oui ce que les touristes tous
les étrangers sera absent alors on a
besoin de ces étrangers pour l'économie
française et restaurants les hôtels tout
et on en a besoin aussi dans les musées
sinon dans vingt ans les musées si on
n'a pas de visiteurs on les entend dire
un mot pour les entretenir moins on va
les fermes et c'est ça qui va se passer
alors on a vraiment besoin de cette vie
et en même temps on a besoin de nouvelle
génération qui on va dire ont d'autres
préoccupations
eh bien elles vont avoir la soudain une
proposition artistique qui leur convient
mieux
et c'est parfait justement vous avez
beaucoup réfléchi pendant cette période
compliquée
[Musique]
de versailles spectacles de toutes plus
compliqué quelle leçon fond vous retenez
de cette période est de cette façon en
font que vous avez eu de répondre à des
attentes nouvelles ou à des des
objectifs nouveaux
je crois que ce que ça nous a peut-être
à tout donner comme le som sek
on ne sait pas de quoi est fait l'avenir
me mais par contre il sera toujours fait
par des gens qui on va dire avance
dedans même dans la difficulté faut
avancer
tork surtout pas du repli ça ne servira
à rien c'est l'immobilisme définitif
mais je crois que celui qui le premier a
trouvé ce vaccin était français il n'a
pas trouvé de preneur en france parce
qu'on n'a pas trop osé on n'était pas
sûr et il ya un américain qui ai dit
voilà le chèque vas-y et il a fait le
vaccin est finalement c'est ça alors
bien sûr à une échelle tout à fait
différent que par les causes et de la
culture doit faire c'est se dire ok on
va faire encore plus de propositions
encore plus d'attentes
parce que demain le public aura encore
plus besoin qu'on lui dise de venir et
d'être satisfait et si on veut garder en
france notamment cette première place
mondiale du tourisme
il faut s'y adapter maintenant parce que
l'évolution redford qui aura de plus en
plus de demandes plus en plus de
touristes ils vont venir par exemple
beaucoup plus d'inde qu'aujourd'hui et
l'inde étant d'une expansion
extraordinaire dans 10 ans ou dans 20
ans à vatry les gencives entre d'afrique
donc soudain ces touristes ne sont pas
ceux d'hier
voilà on a encore l'idée ou c'est
l'écart déjà brillé mais ça fait
longtemps qu'il ya plus de cartes
japonais par contre il ya des brigades
de chinois alors comment on fait
aujourd'hui
eh bien on anticipe et anticiper c'est
se dire ok on va traduire nos documents
dans les langues de ces gens là on va
leur faire des propositions qui leur
conviennent le patrimoine reste le même
mais simplement la manière de leur
apporter le message de versailles doit
être plus le leur est ainsi et c'est la
même chose pour une jeune génération ou
pour un public empêché entre guillemets
en france bien il faut leur donner
versailles parce que c'est notre bien
commun au delà de la france notre bien
commun à tous
et c'est peut-être le plus beau cadeau
qu'on puisse leur faire c'est d'avoir
des idées en avance seulement il faut
savoir se réinventer c'est ce que vous
faites avec l'opéra de versailles avec
versailles spectacles
merci beaucoup leur envol merci patrice
[Musique]
sylvain parent au bonjour bonjour vous
êtes gestionnaire du patrimoine de
domaine de versailles
jardi du domaine de versailles et
combien de serre dinger à peu près on
est à peu près entre 60 et 80 en 60 en
hiver où c'est un petit peu plus calme
et 80 en été on a vraiment besoin de
beaucoup de monde alors on arrive à la
saison de l'été quel travail particulier
déjà dit l'été et bien on a énormément
besoin d'arroser à céret semble assez
logique
bon là on ce moment il pleut il pleut
beaucoup et on en est très heureux on
doit peut-être les rares personnes à
être oui les jardins le moral aussi un
peu bien entendu et on va râler dans pas
très longtemps et 10,4 au chaud mais
hélas pour l'instant voilà c'est le
l'arrosage qui nous prend beaucoup de
temps
on peut en profiter pour tailler
certains végétaux taille et en verre
taillé sur des petites branches on
plante encore quelques quelques annuel
et on tombe beaucoup parce que vous
savez qu'on a comme énormément de
pelouse à verser l'eau qu'on fasse
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à les tondre
justement c'est aussi une période où y'a
du touriste alors même si un petit peu
moins pour les crises sanitaires s'abîme
un peu les jardins les dvd pelouse
oh non non non je vais pas vous dire le
contraire non non on est très heureux
que les temps de trésorerie et qui a
dérivé du tsl et non non les touristes
abîme pas la pelouse
ils peuvent en fait créer ce qu'on
appelle des chemins de désirs ça
s'appelle comme ça oui c'est les
endroits où les les touristes les
visiteurs comptent la pelouse souvent à
angle droit parce que c'est plus simple
et bon c'est vrai que ça abîme un petit
peu peut-être ça gâche un petit peu la
vision mais bien minime 1 quand on voit
la taille et puis ça fait partie de ce
conseil sont personnes alors on a le dos
triadou derrière nous alors là on est
sur un des bras du grand canal le bras
du fer à cheval alors le fer à cheval
c'est cette fontaine qui est derrière
moi elle fonctionne pas actuellement
mais qui marchent pendant les grandes
zones est derrière nous c'est le
bâtiment du grand trianon et d'ailleurs
je vous engage à venir le visiter la saa
et réouvrir est ouvert on peut venir
donc l'après midi et on peut surtout
admirer nos parterres voilà c'est juste
que desjardins du trianon c'est quand
même des chefs-d'oeuvre oui et alors
chaque année maintenant on choisit un
thème l'année dernière c'était des
parterres africain avec très peu de
plantes qui venaient d'afrique et cette
année c'est les parterres vert c'est à
dire qu'on a décliné la couleur verte
dans les feuillages dans les fleurs les
tiges
nous voilà je vous engage à venir le
découvrir et les années prochaines
des thèmes qui sont déjà choisis mais
pour l'instant les gardent secret
d'accord avant d'en parler donc ce sont
les partis il ya un bien on n'est pas
très loin non plus du petit trianon
aussi où il y avait des jardins non on a
aussi donc les jardins anglais du petit
trianon qui valent le coup d'oeil
d'autant qu'en ce moment vous en
parlerai certainement vous en avait
parlé il ya l'exposition des lalanne
oui vision à la fois magnifier
accompagner et rendre encore plus
étonnant ses jardins là
et donc ce sont des jardins à l'anglais
zaveck un dessin typique c'est à dire
que c'est à desjardins qui imite la
nature qu'ils vont recréer un espace qui
se veut naturel mais qui ne l'est pas
puisqu'il est entièrement artificiel et
qui avait été créée exclusivement pour
le plaisir de marie antoinette
c'est ça oui alors là on va visiter
quelque chose qui est ouvert au public
depuis très peu de temps que ça
il s'appelle le rue de gally oui le
russe est un ruisseau c'est ça c'est le
nom ben voilà c'est un petit ruisseau
alors c'est un ruisseau dont l'existence
est attestée dès le xvème siècle on a
des cartes en fait
et avant même que les que louis xiii
louis xiv et les osé mais suivant
construisent le parc du château de
versailles il se rue existait déjà
alors comme il prenait sa source dans sa
vie alors maintenant il la prend dans le
grand canal avant il apprenait au delà
de l'étang des suisses de la pièce de
défense est maintenant en fait sa source
si je puis dire c'est le grand canal
dans le canal
c'est à dire que en fait quand il est
trop plein quand il ya trop d'eau les
fontainiers ouvre des vannes tout
simplement et en fait c'est cette eau
qui va s'écouler dans le rugby
donc ça fait un ruisseau c'est un
ruisseau tout à fait naturel sauf qu'il
a ce qu'on appelle un régime
intermittence à dire qu'il va ne pas
couler en été puisque il ya moins d'eau
forcément et il coulera beaucoup plus en
hiver divers
voilà alors on va aller visiter parce
que mais on peut dire un mot c'est assez
acceptable
cc c'est très j'ai dit presque étrange à
versailles la cc on est on est dans un
autre verset avec moi si je peux dire
mais c'est ça en fait on a voulu créer
accompagné déjà ce ruisseau puisqu'il y
avait déjà une petite promenade et on a
voulu aussi mettre en avant de notre
patrimoine faunistique et floristique
parce que ici il n'ya pas que des grands
arbres il n'y a pas que les aussi des
animaux il ya aussi toute une rive lors
sauvage et naturel il ya aussi une faune
donc on a aussi tout un tas d'oiseau on
a aussi quelques mammifères on a des
chevreuils et on voulait le mettre en
avant où vous voulez aussi insisté sur
le fait que le parc du château de
versailles à l'époque de louis xiv était
une réserve de chasse c'était le plus
grand à l'époque ça faisait huit mille
hectares maintenant ça en fait six ans
et on voulait montrer que maintenant on
a on a conscience de ça et on voulait
créer un refuge un havre de paix pour
les animaux à l'échelle du grand parc
et pour mettre en avant c'est cette
volonté on a créé le rue de gally alors
le rue de galice la promenade du ru de
gally que je vous invite à découvrir est
bon on y va à lausanne
[Musique]
m
sylvain parent ou alors nous sommes là
au début du jeu de galien oui donc on a
voulu créer des panneaux d où explicatif
il y en a 6 ans tous un à l'entrée et à
la sortie et ensuite pour chacun des
quatre écosystèmes qui sont là on a créé
un petit panneau qui est qui est
implantée à peu près au milieu mais qui
explique ce qu'on peut voir quand on a
de la chance quand on fait pas de bruit
et quand tout vous vient à la bonne
période c'est à dire en général c'est
quand même plutôt printemps était
jusqu'à l'automne on peut voir des
oiseaux des insectes des amphibiens et
aussi quelques quelques jolies plantes
donc on a fait faire les dessins par une
illustratrice qui s'appelle emmanuel
tchoukriel qui a fait aussi les dessins
des arbres admirable qui est un autre
malade qu'on propose et donc in glass a
décrit les quatre écoles affûter sa
clairière et donc je vais je vous
emmener allons aller visiter ça
on est dans la futaie c'est ça alors des
coups je peux peut-être que vous ne
savez pas ce que c'est une futaie même
futé en fait c'est un terme de tibi
culture et comme vous pouvez le voir
autour de nous en fait ce sont des
arbres d'âge et d'essences différentes
d'accord tout simplement ah oui alors
c'est à dire que ici bon évidemment on
n'exploite pas le bois mais dans une
forêt qui seraient exploités en fait on
viendrait récolter les vieux arbres et
en coupant les vieux chênes les vieux
fresne où les violets très bon on
créerait de l'espace ont créé une
clairière et du coup il ya plein de
nouveaux de nouveau aux armes qui
pourraient être coincés et là c'est un
peu l'idée en perroquet sauf que nous on
récolte pas on les laisse sur place
mais une fois qu'ils sont couchés une
fois qu'ils sont par terre du coup ça
refait de la lumière ça refait de
l'espace et donc on a fait comme vous le
regardez comme on le voit autour de nous
à vous voyez là y'a là il ya un charme
là il s'agissait oui je suis un grand
troyes c'est quoi un chaîne enchaîne là
on ad on a quelques freine on a ici on
verra un petit peu plus loin après on va
voir des peupliers quelques boulots et
des merisiers aussi des cerisiers
sauvages et en fait ce qui est très bien
c'est que ça crée un couvert pour la
nature pour les animaux et quand comme
je le disais quand on coupe des arbres
on en fait des tas de rondins qui
serviront ensuite d'abri aux hérissons
ou au campagnols qui est les campagnols
qui servent de nourriture après aux
buses et aux faucons crécerelles donc ça
aussi grâce à ça qu'on dirait les
écosystèmes ça en pourrissant le bois
fait venir tout un tas d'insectes de
champignons et qui recrée en fait toute
une chaîne alimentaire c'est ça qui va
revenir dans la nature il n'y a pas de
poubelle tout ça tous se sert exactement
les musées lavoisier rien ne se perd
entre rien ne se crée tout se transforme
c'est génial exactement c'est ça c'est
de l'écologie aussi d'ailleurs abaissé
sa et c'est ça qu'on veut mettre en
valeur ici alors on n'explique pas tout
parce qu'il faudrait mettre des panneaux
je suis mais voilà bon quand on commence
à regarder quand on commence à
s'intéresser
il ya des choses qui paraissent beaucoup
plus évidente
donc ça c'est le premier et écosystèmes
c'est fabuleux
c'est très très bien oui bah oui avec
les canicules qui s'annonce
malheureusement chaque année bah c'est
sûr il aurait il fait déjà frais ray et
oui bête vous bambou le savez sans doute
mais les arbres avec
l'évapotranspiration abaisse la
température de l'endroit où ils sont de
quelques degrés et c'est vrai qu'avec
les changements climatiques ça va être
de plus en plus appréciable disais tout
à l'heure on disait dans un autre
versailles c'est vrai que là on est
droit des jardins à la française
oui c'est vrai il ya des endroits où on
a quand même voulu un petit peu jouer
avec les codes et on le verra peut-être
center mais mais c'est vrai qu'il voit
ici c'est là c'est la forêt voilà alors
va passer un autre deuxième on va aller
voir maintenant la lisière hockey
[Musique]
asseyons-nous rien vous faites marcher
mais on a pensé à tout le monde
non c'est bien mais voilà et on a
construit ses petits bras j'ai pour vous
voilà ça me fait du bien
un soir c'est bien c'est la clairière ça
c'est ça ici c'est la clairière alors il
ya un panneau là juste à côté qui permet
de savoir où évidemment il quels sont
les oiseaux les insectes et jouent à la
wii avec un peu de chance sur les arbres
c'est ça on parlait de vous aviez un
moins de 2 de la foule enfin on retrouve
ici alors on entend les oiseaux
évidemment il ya beaucoup de roseaux ah
oui oui ben là on entend des troglodytes
on a entendu des pinsons tout à l'heure
des mères avec un peu de chance on peut
entendre et voir la fauvette à tête
noire
et alors quand on a vraiment de la
chance et convient assez tôt le matin on
peut voir des héros avant ah oui on a
des airs ou là qui viennent pêcher dans
le rue oui quelques codes quelques
canards colverts aussi de temps en temps
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir on espère voir
revenir le tarin désole c'est un petit
oiseau grand comme un moineau plutôt
noir et jaune
donc je vais revenir parce qu'il dit
mais non mais parce qu en fait voilà on
n'a plus trop et on a pas mal d'eau mais
c'est l'arbre typique des cours d'eau en
france et on en a par là on en a là bas
côté des saules donc avec un peu de
chance on y aura peut-être des terrains
des zones qui vont venir ici pour se
nourrir oui bah moi j'aime beaucoup les
oiseaux les oiseaux sauvages et beige et
une tarte de voir revenir tous ces faits
c'est avec avec lui et puis il ya des
wii bien c'était bien sûr bien sûr on a
aussi bas donc les chevreuils aurait on
en a quelques-uns alors qu' on me
demande souvent si ça abîme les un petit
peu un petit peu les nouvelles
plantations mais moi je trouve qu'on
peut vivre avec la nature alors c'est
pas très grave
on a des lièvres aussi qu'on voit
souvent on a des renards oui on a on a
quand même pas mal de d'animaux qui
viennent chaîne qui habite chez nous
d'ailleurs à kiewit seynois et avec un
peu de chance
voilà c'est on est un peu curieux c'est
on n'a pas de temps c'est ça si on aime
la nature et qu'on aime flâner qu'on
aime se reposer et qu'on a envie de se
laisser surprendre on peut venir se
balader le long des rues de galles il se
traîne un boxer c'est vers lui que s'est
ouverte ou du jour
oui oui alors là on est dans la partie
qui est ouverte tous les jours c'est le
grand parc s'est ouvert là les échanges
il faut regarder au large mais mais oui
c'est ouvert tous les jours c'est
gratuit ça il ya aucun problème on peut
venir en famille entre amis
c'est une belle balade voilà the ballad
et ses voiliers une jolie ballade qui
fait un kilomètre 5
donc on peut prendre le temps et on peut
on a installé des bancs un peu partout
rick secondes et qui sont costauds
existait des arbres qu'on a c'est qu'on
attend qu'on a trouvé mort qu'on a coupé
qui ça vient du coin celles auxquelles
satie formidables ici à tout et tout est
recyclé oui c'est ça c'est ça ouais on
est dans la nature on réutilise tout ce
qu'on peut merci et bravo et merci à
vous merci d'être venus merci beaucoup
[Musique]